adopt a simple habit every single
morning i do a very simple thing i write
down five things that i want that's it
when i start my day after i get up on
the alarm rings i make my bed i pull on
my exercise clothes i set an intention i
high-five myself in the mirror i then go
out into the kitchen i crack open my
high five journal and then inside the
journal there are prompts that walk me
through the steps of visualizing and the
first prompt is dream with the lid off
set your spirit free write down five
things every morning that you want and
this is important because when you get
what you want out of your head
and you physically put them on a piece
of paper research shows that you're 42
more likely to achieve those goals
simply by writing them down that's
pretty cool
secondly your mind is paying attention
and when you take deliberate action and
you write down what you want you are
signaling to your brain
that you
deserve to have these things you're
signaling to your brain that you do want
those things you're not just going to
think about them these are things that
matter to you and that helps train your
mind to allow you to let the desires
flow through you because right now
you're not manifesting properly because
you're not even allowing yourself to
dream with the lid off so that's step
number one you're gonna start writing
down five things that you want every
single morning as a way to train your
mind to let you dream freely want to be
happy build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel is created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only mel robbins
when you wake up generally what the
research shows is that your brain is
primed
to be able to focus
for the first four hours of the day
the first four hours of the day tend to
be for most of us
the time of day when your brain has the
most fuel
and when your speed of processing is
awesome and when you are able to direct
your attention at what you need to be
focused on okay
so now there's a caveat to this
you can manufacture
boosts of productivity and boosts of
feeling like you've got a little bit
more brain power
number one immediately after you
exercise so
if you have a burst of cardio
30 minutes is what a lot of the research
says but if you have a burst of cardio
you will get
a little bit of increase in fuel
another thing that helps is getting
outside getting outside uh when you
start to feel your energy and your focus
start to go to empty getting outside is
another way to give yourself a boost of
brain power
but generally speaking everybody
you need to start to marry
mornings with peak productivity if you
can own your mornings
if you can put that thing that matters
to you first thing in the morning and
make a little bit of progress on it
you are going to start to feel like you
are more in control you're going to
start to see yourself using your best
brain power and your highest level of
fuel
at the thing that matters most to you we
all know
that we need to love ourselves right
how do you do that um
i don't know
what is the action that you take yeah we
all know we're supposed to accept
ourselves
we all know we're supposed to
uh
have self-esteem and self-worth and
self-validation and self-confidence
how do you
build it
and you know the other thing is that we
also are looking outside ourselves
for confirmation validation affirmation
of those things
and so how do you relocate the source of
your self-confidence self-esteem
self-worth self-validation within
yourself so that you're in control of it
big idea right
so
uh let me tell you the story about how i
discovered this because it was not like
a oh how do i have another high five
moment you know
i get fired from my talk show
and i
uh am essentially fired from my dream
job i then start having speech after
speech after speech after speech cancel
then houghton mifflin cancels my
contract for my next book and asks for
me to return money that i've long spent
and why'd they cancel it because because
of pandemic they laid off their two
reasons first of all they were they were
laying off 45 percent of the staff but
more importantly let me take
responsibility i was a year late on
delivering amendments okay so let's be
honest i ghosted my publisher and they
fired me um as they should a long play
to ghost your publisher right
how about spend your money and then
ghost you um but
i found myself again in this like
familiar place having
sort of
echoes back to a decade ago of oh my god
are we in financial free fall again like
is this ride over
kids come home you did like 100 speeches
in a year or prior to that yep or prior
to the show yep and then took a pay cut
to do the show yup
and look i i've been saving money i've
been very smart about about money now
that i've made it we've paid back all of
our debt something we're both really
really proud of
and
at the same time when it's a fan in your
life your old things will get triggered
and what got triggered for me is i'm
about to lose it all again right
meanwhile just like everybody else on
the planet your kids come home and it's
both a blessing and a horror show to
have your children in a state of
distress as the world is in distress and
i just started to feel overwhelmed
and there was this one morning
where um
i
walked into the bathroom
and i was standing in my underwear
brushing my teeth in front of the mirror
and i looked up at the mirror and my
first thought was
uh
i
noticed that my jowls were starting to
look like saddle bags on a pack horse at
the grand canyon
and uh i had like these crazy lines by
my eyes and my neck was really like kind
of saggy and one boob was hanging lower
than the other and my gray hair was
coming in and i and as soon as i started
kind of critiquing my
thoughts or my my looks and appearance
then my mind rich started going i didn't
get that email back to that person and i
got that presentation i need to do and
my god did that speech just cancel again
what am i gonna look down and the dog
needs to be walked and then i think i
got a zoom call in nine minutes like i
gotta get my
and before i knew it my whole mood was
low i felt overwhelmed i had taken
myself down mentally
i just wanted somebody to walk in and be
like mal you it's gonna be okay like you
got this girl like it's lift your head
up you can handle this
i don't know what came over me rich
this is
pathetic
but standing there in my underwear
in front of my bathroom sink
i raise my hand
and high five my reflection
and i cracked a smile because it's so
horny
i even thought of that guy stuart smiley
from the snl skips remember that i'm
nice i'm kind people like me
on with my day
that was it
snapped a photo though no not that one
oh not that one not the first time and
then i kept doing it i did it probably
for
a week or two
and here's the weird thing about it i
started when i woke up after doing this
high five your own reflection in the
mirror thing
i actually started to feel like i was
looking forward to it
and here's why you know i've spent a
lifetime just like you standing in front
of the mirror and what i realize now is
that when i'm standing in front of a
mirror i'm either critiquing
or picking myself apart
or i'm ignoring myself
and when you start to high-five your own
reflection
it starts to build a partnership
within you with yourself
when you walk into the bathroom
and you see your reflection and you've
been greeting it it's like seeing
another person
it's the strangest thing you start to
realize how often you ignore or destroy
yourself when you see yourself or beat
yourself up
and here's what's also crazy
you have a lifetime and this is where
the science gets wacky and i'm going to
hit you with so much science because
this stuff is so cool
you have a lifetime positive association
with high-fiving other people
sure as a runner as a racer you have
gotten so many high-fives rich what does
a high five say to you when somebody
gives you one
you feel seen you feel
appreciated you feel energized by it and
it's a it's an exchange of energy it's
not the same and you talk about this in
the book it's not the same as like
self-talk because there's a
participation involved in it there's
like a communion yes back to it yeah and
you know if you think about it you're so
good
at celebrating seeing and cheering for
other people in your life you plan
birthday parties you reach out to people
when you're worried about them you help
out colleagues you cheer for your
favorite sports teams you high-five
people like rich as they're running
races
past you you buy people's merchandise
you do all kinds of stuff for other
people
but nobody's taught you how to do it for
yourself
in fact the reason why it feels
weird to high-five your own reflection
is because you've been taught to do the
opposite the reason why those positive i
love myself i'm happy with who i am i
accept myself the reason why those
mantras don't work in the beginning
is because
your brain rejects it you've spent a
lifetime
trashing your body trashing yourself
telling yourself you're stupid telling
yourself that you're not good enough
telling yourself that nothing's ever
going to work out for you there is no
way that you're going to be able to
stand in front of a mirror everybody
look yourself in the eye and say today's
the day that i'm going to forget all
that stuff and i'm just going to accept
myself
and the reason why it's not going to
work is because all day long
you then continue to beat yourself up
and so what does work well i'm going to
read from chapter seven
of my new york times bestselling book
the high five habit the place where we
left off for those of you is page 91
where we were talking about training
your mind
to change
the way that it views the world
intentionally training your mind to help
you
and this is an important thing to learn
how to do
because if your mind is going to accept
new ways of thinking and new beliefs
about you you must also train your mind
to start to
see the world differently and so you can
do the exercises that i'm teaching you
in conjunction with what i'm about to
teach you about mantras so
mistake number one when it comes to you
trying to become a more positive person
and when you are trying to change the
way that you talk to yourself is you
pick a mantra
that you do not at your core belief okay
you pick something that is the
antithesis of how you actually believe
it yourself and so the mistake number
one that you're making when it comes to
mantras is that you're picking a mantra
that is so
far away from where you are that your
mind immediately rejects it so that's
mistake number one
mistake number two
is that you pick a mantra
that is simply just you repeating a
statement
that is the exact opposite of how you
speak to yourself and how you treat
yourself all day long and so you know
let me just talk about this on a common
sense standpoint
let's say
that you really want to become healthier
okay
how many of you want to become healthier
right
and you know all the things you need to
do how many of you want to become
healthier and you know the specific
actions you need to take in order to
become healthier
right
of course you know what to do you know
that you could eat
better food
you know that you could get more sleep
you know that you could move your body a
little bit more you know that you could
drink more water you know that you could
lay off the booze and the fatty starchy
foods all those little actions would add
up to a much healthier you are you with
me
yes of course you're with me okay so
knowing what to do is the easy part
knowing kind of what you want that's the
easy part
the problem
with sticking to those changes
is that your own
negative self-talk
trashes you all day long
and the negative self-talk
i'm so fat
oh there i go again
i said i wouldn't have dessert but i did
oh i said i wouldn't drink tonight and i
just did oh i said i was gonna go
gluten-free and i didn't
oh i'm sad so i'm gonna do this oh i
don't feel
like going for a walk all of that
negative thinking and talking
it makes you feel less motivated
and less worthy of the change that you
want
and so if you wake up every day and you
have a dream and a goal of becoming
healthier and you know that today you're
going to move your body and today you're
going to drink more water and today
you're going to cut out the gluten and
today you're going to
uh
do whatever you're going to you're going
gonna uh
donate the clothes that don't fit so you
stop trashing yourself all things that
make you feel better right
if you stand in front of the mirror and
you say
i love you and i accept you exactly how
you are
i love you and you deserve to be you
know like and and and i i love myself
and i i'm i i'm going to be healthy i'm
going to be the best me i can be
and then the next thing you do is you go
into the kitchen
and you glug glug glug glug pour a ton
of cream into your coffee
your mind is immediately gonna go why
did you just do that oh my god here i go
i'm one minute into this
and your own negative self-talk just
overrode what you said in the mirror
that mantra that i love myself and i
accept myself by the time you got into
the kitchen you have already trashed
yourself
the pouring the cream in the coffee
is an example that you don't love
yourself you're not sticking to your
word and now your motivation goes boo
to change right
this is why most mantras are completely
you're picking something you don't
believe
so what will work
because the truth is
research says
that having a positive attitude
having an optimistic attitude
being kind to yourself
is the secret to motivation and
inspiration
when you treat yourself with respect
when you cheer yourself forward when you
forgive yourself when you screw up you
are going to feel more worthy and you're
going to feel more encouraged and you're
going to feel more likely
to pick yourself back up
dump the coffee with the cream out
make the coffee with the plant-based
thing that you said you would drink
shrug your shoulders laugh that you just
instinctively poured the cream in and
then
there you go
take a sip of your coffee
so we know that positive talk helps we
know that kindness helps when it comes
to motivation
the problem is you're picking a mantra
that is so pie in the sky
and it's making you feel far away from
what you want
and so what will work i'll tell you what
works and then i'm going to read to you
from the high five habit
mantras only work
number one
if you believe them
i'm going to say that again mantras only
work
if you believe them
so if you're somebody that has struggled
with self-acceptance
for a very long time
it will not work for you to stand in
front of the mirror when you feel broken
and you're at the beginning of your
journey of taking control of your life
it will not work for you to stand in
front of the mirror and to say
i love and accept myself
because as you stand in front of the
mirror and say that your brain is going
to be like no you don't did you see how
you treated yourself yesterday you do
all opens accept yourself i know i'm a
ventriloquist now i'm your brain
and then that truth
that your actions don't align with what
you're saying
plummets your motivation and your desire
to change
so what you have to do is pick a mantra
that you actually believe
when i hear the word productivity
i don't want you to think about plowing
through a to-do list
because part of the reason why you don't
feel productive
is because you're busy doing the things
that aren't important to you
yeah do you need to make sure you have
milk or you got almond milk or oat milk
in the fridge of course you do but have
you ever noticed that all the busy crap
in life
uh tends to take care of itself
that you don't really need to focus your
time and energy on the minutia that's on
your to-do list because that stuff tends
to grab your attention
what you really need to do is figure out
how to create time and how to create the
focus that you need
in order to feel like you are making
progress
on the important things
and that's really
what productivity means to me
you get all kinds of stuff done you're
really busy in your life aren't you
but are you getting
progress made on the important things
probably not because that's the
challenge for most of us and so first
things first when it comes to trying to
have a breakthrough in productivity you
need a game plan
you need to have a very short list every
week of what actually matters to you
okay
because i guarantee you if you were to
do an audit of the way that you spend
your time this week you would probably
see
that 95 of your time
is spent on things that you really don't
care about
and even more scary i bet you don't even
realize how much time you are wasting
just mindlessly scrolling through social
media or sitting on the couch with the
tv on also answering emails
that is the least productive way to
spend your time multitasking spending
your time just sort of zoning out on
things that don't matter
what i want you to do is i want you
right now to think about
what is it between now and the end of
this week for example what is it
that matters to you what's the most
important thing
that you would love to make progress on
that you never seem to find the time
okay
it's a whole nother conversation for us
to talk about whether or not you
actually have time because the fact is
you do have time you have plenty of time
to make small amount of progress every
single day on what matters to you
what you do not have right now is you do
not have a plan
for
prioritizing
the important stuff in your life 50 of
men and women will not or do not look at
themselves in the mirror
because they do not like the person that
they see
and if you can't even look yourself in
the eyes in the mirror that is a habit
of self-rejection
that means you are starting your day
by rejecting yourself
and that's why so many of us race out
into the world and seek validation from
partners and friends and boyfriends and
caregivers and girlfriends and bosses
because we haven't even given ourself
the respect we deserve
and so i want to teach you how to bring
it back home because for those of us
that look in the mirror
we see the things we don't like
the gray hair the saggy boobs the like
you know dark circles
the wrinkles the turkey neck you know
you just pick yourself apart you don't
even realize it this is part of your
morning routine
this is the part where you stand in
front of the mirror and just trash
yourself
we're gonna change that using science
what i want you to do is you're going to
look yourself in the eyes
take a minute that's not a reflection
that's a human being in the mirror and
she needs you
she is tired of your negativity she is
tired of bob running
in your head she's working hard she
needs you to show up
and then you are going to raise your
hand as cheesy as it sounds and you're
going to high-five the woman you see in
the mirror
that's it do not say a word
do not have a mantra
because your brain isn't ready for it
yet
i want you to turn to the person next to
you we're gonna count backwards of five
and then we're gonna give each other a
high five and explain something ready
turn to the person next to you yeah i
don't don't i was like
here we go five four
three
two
one okay great
okay
so let me tell you what's going on here
let me tell you i know we gotta wrap it
up okay what's going on here is
never in the history of high fives have
you high-fived somebody and thought i
hate you
you look terrible today
if you're in a sports team and you screw
up a shot and you come back to a huddle
what do you hope your coach and your
teammates say to you good good try yeah
and if they hand you a high five to send
you back in the game what does a high
five say good episode good effort i
believe in you keep going i you know
like on and on it is always positive
remember how i talked about the fact
that your brain is a pattern learning
machine your brain knows the pattern of
a high five
it has a lifetime of experience with
them
so all the programming's here everybody
when you stand in front of a mirror and
you physically do a high five it grabs
all the neural association in your brain
and it aims it at your face
literally it shuts down bob broccoli
tomato maria whatever we're caring you
know that we're saying the name is
shuts it down because you can't think
something negative while you're doing
this because your brain won't allow it
it's not programmed that way
it takes less than five days
for you to be able to stare at yourself
in the mirror and see a woman that
you're rooting for
your brain every time you do it gives
you a drip of dopamine that's why you
guys laughed it's not from the slap of
the hand it's what your brain's doing
you feel a little bit energized don't
you
that is your nervous system giving you a
little jolt of energy
the five second rule 54321 and a high
five in the mirror after you brush your
teeth are two free science-backed tools
that you can use to interrupt old
patterns that are holding you back and
to start to create new ones that will
push you forward
because that is where you're headed
we're not looking back
i want you to look forward
and i want you to
quiet the noise shut it down in your
head and listen to what's in your heart
and in your gut
because that's what's meant for you
and all you have to do is wake up every
day and if yesterday blew okay
it was whatever we're gonna shake it off
we're gonna high five that off you
didn't go to the gym no problem you're
still gonna give yourself a high five
today you didn't make that phone call
you said no problem you still get a high
five today because you need to send
yourself into the game of life every day
knowing that you have your own back that
you believe in you
and the way that you prove that is
through the actions that you take
and 30 minutes a day
just for you
to focus on you to set your day up
because how you set your day up is how
it ends up
you deserve that
and that's how you claim it
and trust me you're never gonna feel
like it but i want you to do it anyway
you got it got it good
if you expect to achieve your goals if
you expect to
reach your potential if you expect to
have your dreams come true what i'm
about to explain to you is mission
critical you must become a master
at visualization
now
for those of you
that are like what the heck is she
talking about i did not sign up for some
sort of meditation woo spiritual thing
here
don't worry this is mel robbins
there's always science and research
involved in everything that i talk about
so visualization
is a
extraordinarily
powerful skill
and
you may have heard of the law of
attraction
you may have heard of the word
visualization you may have heard of the
word manifesting
i call it um
seeing signs
so i'm a master
at seeing positive signs i am a master
of creating coincidences i have the
world's most incredible luck you want to
know why because i understand the
science and the skill of visualization
i know that your brain
it is a gigantic
detective machine
your brain is a filter your brain is
constantly looking for evidence
and that's good news it's good news when
you know how to use it to your advantage
let me explain
so
your brain has a system in it here's the
technical term it's called the reticular
activating system
it is a network of neurons all up in
here and what is the job of the
reticular activating system
it is a filter system
it's basically a system that allows
certain information in your brain
and it
blocks out other information
and guess who programmed that filter
you did
and so did the people from your past
and so if you constantly feel like
you're unlovable guess what your
reticular activating system is going
through the day and it is going to point
out every single piece of evidence that
confirms that negative belief that you
have
if you think that people don't like you
at work the reticular activating system
the filter it is literally going to be
looking for evidence
to confirm that belief all day long
this is one of the reasons why we have
such a problem with politics in this
country this is why there's something
called a confirmation bias confirmation
bias means your mind loves to read
things that you agree with
because reading things that you agree
with
confirms your filter
why do we have a reticular activating
system there's a really important reason
why you have this the reason why is if
your brain let in everything
have you ever looked
at a facebook page
have you noticed
how many words are on a standard
facebook page and the ad over here and
the ad over here and the ad over here
and the ad in the zoo seed right here
and the stuff up here and all this over
here
if your brain took in everything at
equal value
your head would literally explode off
your shoulders your brain would melt
down and so the reticular activating
system
protects your brain
by filtering information and only
letting in stuff that it agrees with
so
that's the scientific
reason and mandate for why
you got to get busy reprogramming that
thing one of the beliefs that i had for
a very long time is that i was a bad
person
that i was not lovable that um i did not
deserve to be a good person that people
didn't think i was a good person and
consequently that led me to do a lot of
hurtful things to myself it led me to do
a lot of hurtful things to
uh people that i cared about and it it
really
damaged decades of my life
and i believed it i believed it and it
drove my actions and i saw evidence
everywhere if you're going to do a
mindset reset you've got to change what
you believe about yourself and so for
those of you that had a very negative uh
assessment of 2018 and you're feeling
down about your goals already as you
look at 2019 you have a very negative
belief system about yourself
and that's going to stop right now
letting go
is really really hard
and when you are going to start a new
chapter in your life when you're going
to try to launch yourself
forward
it requires you to let go
and the reason why letting go of
whatever it may be a relationship a
friendship a job
my case the place that you lived for the
24 years the reason why letting go is so
hard is because we tend to grip
very tightly
to things that are familiar
and when you grip
really tightly
to the things that you know
it's going to be really hard in fact
it's going to be impossible to launch
yourself forward
and we grip really tightly to the things
that we know
um because
it feels safe
and the truth is change is really really
really hard
because you're holding on to things that
are no longer meant for you
if this is speaking to you i want you to
write into the comments right now
what are you holding on to
whether it's out of fear or self-doubt
or overwhelm you're just gripping so
tightly
what are you holding on to that you know
is no longer meant for you i guarantee
you you're probably gonna write a
friendship a job
a relationship
uh maybe it's a way of eating or
treating your body
maybe it's a way of thinking that you're
holding on to maybe you're just gripping
tightly
to staying stressed and tense and in a
state of fear
you can
hold on to a way of thinking and that
can keep you stuck for decades
i wanted to bring this up because i have
been thinking a lot about this idea of
gripping and holding on
and i think if you if you've followed me
for a while
you've probably heard me say
that you are one decision away
[Music]
from
a different life
better life a life that is full of more
joy
full of happiness full of you feeling
connected and alive and
just engaged in your life again just one
decision away
and the first decision
that will change everything is to let go
to stop gripping
and to find the
confidence and the courage and the
clarity to let go of what's no longer
serving you
and to turn yourself toward what you
truly want in your life
tell me is there
some project
or some area of your life
or
a business or a goal
or some change that you want to make
that
you feel
like you think about all the time but
you just can't seem
to push through
all of that thinking
or push through the the the fatigue or
the overwhelm or how do i get started
right
you can't seem to just push through is
there some area of your life where you
feel that way
if so i want you to write it in the
comments okay i see i want to work with
animals i see somebody going oh my gosh
i keep thinking about doing a tick tock
account oh i want to get control of my
addiction oh i want to launch a business
oh i really want to get a degree but i
feel like it's too late
um and you may be telling yourself
uh that uh things just feel like it's
too late mel like i i got a divorce and
now it feels like my life is
frozen i see some of you saying
i feel like
ever since i got the divorce or the
pandemic hit or i lost the job or i took
the wrong job or i moved to the wrong
place or i realized that i wanted to
start this thing and i started it but
now
it's stalled out and embarrassed to keep
starting i want to finish my phd i want
to be persistent with the gym i want to
get back to creating art i see all the
stuff that y'all are writing down it's
beautiful i see so many of you saying
that you have a little side hustle and
you know that you want to turn your
attention towards it but you just can't
seem
to literally push through
whatever it is the fear the overwhelm
the business of your life to laser focus
on what really matters to you
and i think that's why it's so painful
because you're not going to stop
really wanting and longing for those
things that you keep thinking about
everybody
they're going to linger for the rest of
your life
you're going to have to at some point
make a decision
that it is important enough to you
to
make changes so that the thing that you
want to see happen or the life that you
don't want to miss out on
or the degree that you always
longed to get
or the way that you want to feel in your
body or the energy for me a big theme
recently has been about loneliness
i am so
lonely in my personal life because
of the pandemic because our kids have
launched because we're moving to vermont
because i'm always working like i can
see very clearly
that i have
tried to solve loneliness in my personal
life by working all the time
and
that's not the right solution for
loneliness and so
i even
see all this and so
i'm glad that you can see an area of
your life
where you feel this friction and tension
because you know that you want to focus
more time and energy there
but there's so much resistance and
there's so much friction and there's so
much else going on that it is robbing
you
of the ability
to push forward toward the life
that you really want to be living
and look it's not going to happen
overnight but so let me tell you let me
tell you
this sentence this truth about life that
i truly love that that always kicks me
in the rear end honestly and here it is
no one is coming
that's it no one's coming
no one is going to come into your life
and do the work for you no one is going
to come into your life and
uh just remove your problems
no one is going to come into your life
and
uh make your dreams come true
when it comes to the changes that you
want to make when it comes to the things
that you long for in your heart when it
comes to the music that you want to put
out into the world or the tick tock
account that you want to create or the
degree that you want to get or the life
you want to build after divorce or after
your partner dies or
after you know you change jobs or after
the kids launch when it comes to those
things that you deeply long for deserve
and desire no one's
coming you are not too late
if you're breathing you're watching this
video you have plenty of time
to create a life that makes you happy to
create a life that is full of meaning
for you whatever that means
you have plenty of time to take control
to heal it is so important for you to
hear that that you have plenty of time
but no one's coming
at some point you have to make a
decision and you'll often hear me say
you're one decision away
from a different life a better life
but you have to make the decision no
one's coming to make the decision for
you you have to decide that you are done
feeling
beaten up you're done
feeling lost you're done feeling stuck
you're done feeling isolated that all
that crap that you've been enduring
you're freaking done
you have to decide that the secret to an
optimistic mindset you got to be
maniacal about your intake
negativity in here means negativity in
your body gets stored here and
negativity comes out here
it becomes this loop of negativity
and so in order to build a positive
mindset i want you to be maniacal about
positive input
that means
really watch your news intake
do not be watching it every day get the
facts
get what you need to know from a trusted
measured
calm
factual source
and then turn that off okay that's
number one number two edit your social
media
anything on your social media feeds
should be
helping you be more resilient
more optimistic
more um
positive
anything
that you're following that triggers you
that is negative that rubs you the wrong
way you know one of the things that i've
noticed
i have some favorite celebrities that i
have um followed for a while because i
think they're funny or i love um
just kind of their sense of humor
but there are so many people that i have
muted right now because i think that
what they're doing online is so freaking
out of whack
seeing people give us advice about
quarantining from the back of their
estates and mansions telling us to
donate when they're not saying they're
donating
seeing this kind of tone-deaf
celebrity thing going on i'm normally
not a negative person about that but i
have muted muted muted so many accounts
because it's not doing anything for me
and you got to be selfish right now you
have got to edit your social media feeds
so that your social media feeds are
helping you build an optimistic and
positive mindset and so every day the
second i see summer at mute mute mute
mute unfollow unfollow unfollow because
negativity in means negativity gets
stored here but negativity goes out
there from you you want to put
positivity optimism tools strategies
things that keep you laughing keep
things that keep you giving you things
that you can use right now
the second you start getting overloaded
with corona stuff mute that stuff edit
edit edit your social media based on
what you need part of the reason why you
don't feel productive is because you're
trying to complete everything and so
let's take one of the things that i saw
somebody write that you want to uh clean
up one of the spare rooms in your
apartment or in your house that maybe
there's a spare bedroom and you have
been wanting to turn it into a home
office or maybe one of the kids has
moved out of the house and you want to
declutter that room like a project
around organizing maybe it's something
in your garage or your basement or hey
here's one for me uh our daughter moved
out and started her life
uh you know post college and our other
daughter is out in los angeles going to
college and we no joke
have
three garbage bags full of clothes
that somebody needs to go through to
figure out what needs to be donated what
could you actually sell because it still
has tags on it
and it has been sitting there for two
months so maybe you have a pile of that
kind of stuff in your house this is not
a priority for me
i'm perfectly fine with it sitting in
the room where our laundry is the
priority for me this week is to carve
out dedicated time to hang out with our
16 year old son and do something fun
together because we spend a lot of time
together but we don't get intentional
about doing something specific but if
you want to declutter for example here's
where we all go wrong you identify what
you want to do and then you think you
got to get it done
in order for me to go through two bags
of clothing for example in order for you
to clear out your garage
that could take you two days to do it
the right way right
because
you know if you don't give yourself
enough time then you're gonna piles and
so then you think i can't get it done
and so then you never schedule it right
okay
we're not going to worry about
completion everybody
we're going to worry about progress
so when you think about things in terms
of progress
it can shrink the amount of time that
you need
maybe all that you're going to do is
you're going to work on one dresser in
the room
or you're going to work on one shelving
unit in the garage
and by simply making the time to number
one identify what matters to you and
number two identify what meaningful
progress could look like
you will now shrink the amount of time
you will define the project and you can
make the time for it and simply just
doing that is going to make you feel
more productive based on the research
all right now let me talk about um
what you need to do okay i literally
have notes for this oh there we go and i
just lost it because i really want to
make sure that i teach you all this
stuff
so um here becca can you help me because
this is not oh because my thing is not
never mind guys i am tr i am trying
multitasking is not how you be
productive and you are watching me
multitask right now
we're going to get into some of the
science now
so now that is how you leverage
something called the progress principle
okay the progress principle is really
important when it comes to productivity
this is a concept that i first learned
about in the harvard business review so
if it's in the harvard business review
everybody very fancy must be accurate
right if it's coming from harvard well
the progress principle is a study that
uh comes from a study where researchers
looked at i believe it was 14 000 work
journals and what they found after
looking at the work journals of how
people spent their time 14 000 people is
that at the end of the week the people
that felt like they had been the most
productive and the people who felt the
most fulfilled by their work week were
the people who simply made progress
on something that mattered and so by you
identifying what matters to you this
week and by you identifying a way that
you can make a small amount of progress
on it you are leveraging this research
research from harvard business review
about what creates productivity and
meaning and fulfillment in your life and
that's making progress on something that
matters you need to do the work okay
you got to do the work
because it's only through your actions
that you will accomplish what you want
let's say uh that you've always wanted
to climb a particular mountain okay
there's a mountain called haystack it's
not even that tall so i should probably
pick a bigger one but let's just call it
haystack mountain you've always wanted
to climb haystack mountain you pull up
to haystack mountain
and you get out of the car you park at
the you know national forest parking lot
and you make the mistake of looking up
at the mountain which is the end goal
right
and you notice it's up in the clouds
and then you start to think oh my god
that's a really far way away
you know i don't really know how i feel
about doing this anymore because that
looks like it's going to take a really
long time and then all of a sudden it
starts to rain and you go i don't think
i want to do this because i don't think
i feel like doing this and next thing
you know you are back in the car driving
back down the road to that little diner
that you saw and instead of climbing the
mountain that you've always dreamt of
climbing you've now
come up with an excuse
and you have abandoned ship you now have
literally become your own obstacle you
talked yourself out of it you started to
doubt yourself you told yourself you
weren't ready and that you didn't feel
like it
you pull the rip cord you're out of
there in order to have what you want in
life
you must stop staring at the top of that
mountain you must stop creating excuses
for why you can't or don't feel like it
and you must put your head down
and look at the first step in front of
you
and then you must take the action and
start walking toward what you want and
it'll be a hell of a lot easier for you
to do that if you have also
been putting in the time every day
consistently to not only see yourself
walking up that trail step by step but
that you have felt yourself pushing
through the resistance the fear the
obstacles the the excuses that are
stopping you now and feel proud in every
fiber of your being as you push through
those obstacles and see yourself and
feel yourself doing the work that's how
you manifest properly
and if you do that before you pull into
the
national park parking lot
if you look up at that mountain and you
see clouds and it starts raining it
won't matter
because you've already rehearsed this
moment in your mind body and spirit
and you my friend will start walking up
that trail
and you're going to be proud the reason
why visualization and picturing yourself
succeeding and allowing yourself to feel
the happiness and the pride that comes
with picturing a positive future
the reason why that's as important is
let's say shelley does that every single
day this week
every day she wakes up she walks for
five minutes and as she's walking on
that treadmill she's visualizing herself
finishing a 10k in six months and how
proud she is
every time she does that she is
changing what's going on up here
this isn't something i made up this is
true
and it's not only true based on science
but let's think about this from a common
sense perspective if shelley wakes up or
if you wake up every single morning
and instead of thinking about the worst
case instead of looking at your body in
the mirror and going i'm so fat i'm so
out of shape i'll never run a 10k this
is never going to happen why didn't i
exercise last year i hate my flabby
stomach i hate my my big thighs i hate
how out of shape i'm embarrassed to go
like if that's what you're thinking
then that is what
you're allowing your brain
to continue to filter the world through
if you start
teaching yourself the skill of
visualizing a positive outcome and
feeling the pride that comes with
achieving that positive goal what
happens for you right now
is you start to think like the kind of
person that does a 10k
if after an entire week what shelly does
is she get looks in the mirror and she
goes i'm getting stronger every day i'm
really proud of myself even though i'm
i'm feeling flabby i'm not saying you're
flabby shelly but even though i'm
feeling flabby i'm doing the work i can
do this what happens a week from now is
when she sees a registration for a 10k
the old mind that wasn't programmed
correctly would go oh you're fat you're
out of shape you're not prepared for
that don't sign up
but the new mind
because she's been visualizing every
single day
the new mind just seven to ten days
later is gonna go oh wait a minute i'm
in shape i'm proud i'm doing this why
don't you sign up
it's gonna filter the world in a very
different way because you're training it
to
this is the heart of doing a mindset
reset and this is why visualization
works and why it's an important step and
why i'm so glad you're doing it if you
struggle with boundaries i want you to
know you're not alone and this is super
common
and um one of the reasons why i'm
excited to share everything that i've
learned about boundaries with you is
because i used to be the kind of person
that had zero boundaries i mean nada
nothing zilch nothing in fact there were
periods of my life where it was worse
than zero because i was so attached in
romantic relationships that i literally
would become like a human amoeba
in my romantic relationships i mean i
was like literally if it's possible to
have negative boundaries meaning you
like somehow go in a totally different
direction
that was me and so if somebody as
insecure
and as uh emotionally attached in
relationships and as people-pleasing as
me can figure out how to
identify
communicate
and uphold boundaries in my life
you can learn how to do this too okay
and so that's what we're gonna unpack
in this video
so i think a big question because a lot
of people talk about boundaries they
know they need boundaries but they don't
have good boundaries why is that
well the reason why
we don't have good boundaries is because
none of us were trained how to set them
i mean i want you to think about your
childhood for a minute
your childhood with your caregivers your
parents your grandparents whoever it is
naturally an imbalance right
like when you come into this world you
are born into a particular family you're
born into a particular culture religion
economic situation a place in the world
a race like a religion
and
based on where you were born and to whom
you were born into in terms of the
family structure
there were all kinds of rules that you
had to follow and if you did not follow
those rules
there were consequences
and so can you imagine
if you as like an eight-year-old started
to try to express boundaries literally
like mom cooks a uh you know a pot pot
roast dinner and you cross your arms
you're like you know mom
this is a boundary cross for me i have
decided that i am no longer eating meat
uh your mom would probably go guess what
youngster
you not eating dinner is a boundary
crossing for me you're not getting up
from this table until you finish what's
on your plate and so
saying boundaries when you're little
doesn't really work for the adults in
your life and that's why you never
learned how to do it and by the way your
parents were probably never taught how
to have boundaries either and so
i want to start at the very beginning
okay
where do you even begin
where do you even begin when it comes to
learning how to set healthy boundaries
okay
so
first things first where you're gonna
begin is you're going to start to think
about boundaries in a completely new way
okay
the number one mistake that we all make
i made it you're making it right now is
when you think about boundaries you are
thinking about other people first okay
you're thinking about boundaries uh and
believing that your boundaries are rules
in a relationship that define respect
and that somehow your boundaries are
going to control or change someone
else's behavior
that is the exact opposite of how you
should be thinking about boundaries okay
and i'm going to give you a bunch of
examples don't worry i didn't realize
this this is why i was lousy at setting
boundaries because i thought that my
boundaries control what other people do
no no no no so how do i want you to
think about boundaries okay
boundaries
are rules
that you create
about your own behavior
yep i'm going to say that again
boundaries are rules that you create
about your own behavior
you can find people to support you
you will always find people to criticize
you
watch though how when somebody outside
of you criticizes you
how that triggers the internal pattern
so what is the pattern that you have of
thinking
that gets triggered that disempowers you
that i won't have any words you won't
have any words let's go deeper than that
is it something about being loved or
being unworthy or not being good enough
what is underneath i won't have the
words
yeah they won't be the right words and i
it won't be good enough yeah okay and so
do you have an opinion that you're not
good enough or not deserving of success
or that you're not
smart enough to make a difference
yeah what is the one what is what is the
thing that hooks you that you say to
yourself
that i'm stupid that they're okay there
we go that's a good one not a good one
but you know what i mean that's a good
one
okay i'm a piece
now we're talking yeah that's the big
one who told you that
i don't i don't know who told me that
when did you start believing that
it's a little girl yeah
god i've just been saying it for so long
i i don't know
that's okay she said i've been saying it
for so long i don't know
as you now know what you're looking for
you're gonna start to connect the dots
okay and so here's the thing
at some point
you started telling yourself whatever
i'm a piece as a strategy
you did it on purpose as a youngster
as a way to survive things that were
happening because maybe when you said
well i'm a piece you actually got really
quiet and you didn't get hit
or maybe when you said that you uh
removed yourself from situations
when you would have been abused or
something it worked because it protected
you as weird as it sounds yeah
is that are you seeing something what
are you seeing
well yeah my dad didn't want he wanted
me to be quiet in the corner being quiet
yeah we couldn't
make noise and okay
and if you got if you raised your voice
you got in trouble so do you guys see
the link now between why she has a
concern about finding her words
oh yeah i didn't get that one you see
that now yeah so
every time that you
are in a situation where you need to
speak up how many of you relating to
this by the way
i have a theory about all of us
that we have
patterns and strategies that we we
created when we were little
in order to survive
and what she
internalized was don't speak up
and you're a piece you do
and
believe me that protected your ass it
worked because you didn't speak up and
you didn't get in trouble with your dad
right and i still got the love so if i
speak up now i'm going to lose my dad's
love do you see this
so this is a pattern that got
written when she was little
and it was written by someone else and
it worked it worked
the problem is now that you're working
now it's not working now
it's not working now not working now and
see
exactly and so this is what's
fascinating about all this there are
places in your life where you have
patterns that you don't even recognize
that were strategies that you developed
when you were a kid and so in the areas
where you're really frustrated that
pattern is probably
not
present or conscious
something that you're aware of
and so every single time because you've
been repeating this and repeating it and
repeating it every single time you're
about to hit play every single time
you're going to stand on stage what's
going to be right there is don't speak
up
you're yes freeze and you're going to go
5-4-3-2-1
the only thing to
that actually overrides this pattern is
to speak
and through speaking
you will see
that you're not a pc
you actually have something to say
or you could make fun of it and say well
i guess i'm just a piece of something to
say
that's going to be my thing yes
that's right and i also like the
strategy of kind of making the fun of
the stuff
even the heavy stuff
because it loses its grip on me it works
for me it may not work for you
but it's something to try okay you got
it thank you so many of us have this
perfectionism gene and the reason why
we're perfectionists is we're trying to
insulate ourselves from criticism that
if you get it perfect no one will give
you feedback if you get it right
nobody's going to criticize you if you
do it perfect then no one will be able
to attack you and the problem with that
and that's just another side of the same
coin which is the fear of disappointing
people you're managing not disappointing
people not by lying and not by being
codependent but by actually trying to be
a perfectionist so that nobody
criticizes you so let me tell you a
story about the fear of disappointing
people in my own life because this is
the biggest trigger in my life i mean it
goes back to being in fourth grade right
it's there and this is another thing i i
literally have to remind myself of this
everybody every single day you cannot
remove the things that trigger you you
can't if you've been doing a pattern
since fourth grade there will be things
for the rest of your life that will
trigger that pattern to come up but you
can always choose not to repeat the
pattern so you'll be triggered and be
afraid that you're going to disappoint
somebody that's real that's normal it's
natural it's part of being a human being
i think it's interwoven into every
relationship where you love somebody but
you don't have to behave the way that
you always behaved when you're nervous
about disappointing somebody so let me
give you a dumb story you ready when my
husband and i got married my father gave
us this really incredible gift he gave
us an antique pool table i grew up in
muskegon michigan where brunswick was
founded and my dad has a hobby of going
to garage sales and estate sales and
buying old dilapidated pool tables and
then he restores them so when chris and
i got married he bought us an old
dilapidated pool table from the same era
as our house which is the 1870s he
restored the whole thing and then
recently he and i rented a u-haul and we
drove this sucker from muskegon michigan
to boston massachusetts my dad and i
took a road trip get there and we
assemble the pool table in what used to
be our playroom fast forward three or
four years the speaking business takes
off my business starts to grow we have
people that work for us and my kids are
older we don't need a playroom we need
an office the pool table is in the
middle of this thing for the first two
years of having the office we kept the
pool table there why because i didn't
want my dad to be disappointed because i
love him now he visits our house twice a
year for two or three days with my mom
and i kept this thing occupying a third
of our office for two years and then i
realized i'm being ridiculous i'm being
absolutely ridiculous now here's the
thing will he be disappointed if i take
the pool table down absolutely
definitely there are always going to be
things that you do decisions that you
have to make in your life in your
business for your family that will
disappoint other people it's unavoidable
but the fact that he's going to be
disappointed should never be the reason
that i don't do something that is
aligned with my values now let's take it
a step further when you make a decision
that is likely going to disappoint
people or that does still make the
decision because it's your life there's
nothing worse than when you start to rob
your future and your life and your
happiness because you're so focused on
other people however if you love people
you can still take care of them when you
make that decision so let me go back to
the example of the pool table so i knew
i was going to take it down i knew my
father was going to be disappointed i
was disappointed i don't have a big
house so i don't you know i don't have
the room for a huge pool table i don't
have a finished basement like a lot of
people i don't have like a cool garage
game room thing like i just don't have
it i called him first and said i need to
talk to you about something you know the
pool table i love the pool table dad my
business is growing so much i actually
need an office and oh great it'll be
great in the office and i'm like well
yeah it would except i have you know
three or four people showing up we got
to put some desks in there for now even
went down well you could put a piece of
plywood they could work on the pool
table and then they could do the thing
and then the thing and now my heart is
racing because i don't want to
disappoint my dad and now he's fighting
for the and i had to just say for me dad
here's what's going to happen i'm going
to hire professional movers in the pool
table business to disassemble this with
love and care you're going to store it
beautifully when i either get a
full-time office off-site or i build a
barn or i build a different house this
will have its own beautiful room
dedicated to you so we had this
beautiful conversation now was he
disappointed absolutely when they come
to the house and visit which they just
did and they walk into the office do i
feel a pang you better believe i do it
doesn't matter that's all normal i still
need to make the decisions that i need
to make and the difference what's
changed is how i relate to that fear so
instead of what i would do in the past
is i would make a decision that doesn't
serve me i'd leave the pool table and
then i'd be all about it i'd leave the
pool table as a way to make my dad happy
but it makes me miserable to leave it
there because i need the space right and
then i'd be kind of annoyed and then
he'd come and i'd fake play pool because
i kind of want to write you know you
know what i'm saying like we do all this
that's not real and what i've been able
to do for myself in some instances when
i catch it is to hit it head on and to
be authentic and to still take care of
people and what i've also come to learn
is that people can be disappointed in
you and they still love you you know
you're never gonna get around this
everybody in your family is gonna be
disappointed with you probably once a
day probably and you have the ability to
retrain how you respond to that trigger
that rises up in you where you start to
fear that you're disappointing somebody
and the answer really is make the
decision that's aligned with your values
and the thing that supports you and then
take care of the person by being honest
and straightforward about it dealing
with their disappointment head on
because that's really the adult thing to
do and that's what you do when you love
somebody the way we've all been handling
it myself included is manipulation lying
resentment withholding and that doesn't
serve anybody
your thoughts lead you
in a particular direction and if you
start to
allow your mind to dwell on negative
outcomes if you start to obsess that
things are not going to work out if you
allow yourself to continue
to
think negative thoughts you're not only
priming your mind to default to negative
but you will literally
through your thoughts trigger negative
actions you know if you think about it
you've had experiences in your life
right where you've really
trashed yourself you've hated on
yourself and when you continually think
that you hate yourself or you
continually
tell yourself that you're screwing up
you tend to do things that you hate
don't you but when you're in a positive
mindset when you're in an optimistic
mindset when you interrupt those
negative thoughts and you start to say
well maybe it is gonna work out or you
know i gotta just keep on going your
thoughts
literally can trigger positive action
too i find that even when change is
exciting
it's still scary
even when you know
that this big move that you want to make
this big goal that you want to achieve
is something that you're meant to do
even though you know it it feels
overwhelming
we found an incredible apartment in
boston and um are negotiating right now
uh a place and i had nightmares last
night
about this apartment nightmares
why
well because anything new any change
that you want to make is going to
require you
to literally
end things in your old life you see i
think that so many of us we are really
there are two lives that we have there's
the life that you're currently living
and then there's the one
that you're going to live next hello
whoever's flying that jet i'm going to
say that again we all have two lives
the life you're currently living
and the life
you're going to launch next
and when you're in the middle of
thinking about changes and making big
changes in your life
i feel like it's almost like you're
walking across a suspension bridge as
you're building it
and so i have become so indecisive about
everything like i i noticed last night i
was trying to reach out to somebody that
was recommended to me as a potential
person to hire as an executive producer
for this big podcast for launching this
fall in boston
and i couldn't even
get myself focused to write the email
now the reason why is because when
you're on edge when you're overwhelmed
when you feel stressed or scared about
something your nervous system kicks into
a state of alert and that impacts your
brain's ability to focus
so what do you need
when you feel that way i'll tell you
what you need you need to hit the
freaking reset button you need to get
your mindset back in check you gotta
focus on the simple things that you can
do every day to make yourself feel
steady and secure and clear even as
everything is changing around you you
want to focus on what's in your control
okay
that's what you want to do
if you're going through a divorce you're
waiting for lawyers and this process of
anticipation this process of having to
be patient the first thing that you need
to do is ask yourself and this is by the
way stuff that i talk about in the high
five habit book this is about how to
cultivate a high five attitude
when things are out of your control
how to cultivate a high five attitude
when you are waiting
and uh are feeling this anticipation
how to cultivate a high five attitude
when you might be disappointed
i mean you're not going to have
everything be a win in life
and so
rule number one
you want to put
150 percent
effort in
on something that you care about okay so
if you are sitting here and you're
waiting to hear back on something or
you're waiting to do something you want
to ask yourself if i put 150 in one of
the reasons why i just fired off
literally a three-page detailed email to
this landlord basically saying these
girls need a win
they all have uh jobs after working uh
internships uh their senior year
they are respectful they're not looking
at your house like a frat house like so
many other people will they need
individual rooms in case they have to
work remote like i went boom boom boom
boom boom they're looking for a home
why did i do that because i think it's
really important when you are trying to
make something happen in your life
really important when you're going for
something that you can personally say to
yourself i have done a hundred and fifty
percent i have gone
all
in
okay
and so i feel like yeah we went all in
we got our application in
we got the check submitted
we got the uh love letter submitted and
now what i do when i'm waiting
is i literally say i've put in 150
i can give myself that high five i can
look the woman in the mirror and i can
say i know i did everything that i could
what will eat you alive everybody
is if you're waiting
and you know that you didn't put 150 in
it will eat you alive
to
be
waiting
to hear back on a job or on um
you know some test results or on an
application to a program or a school and
to know that you didn't put in 150
that's what's going to cause the
disappointment if you know the moment
that you started to think wow i got to
change myself to fit in i can't be gay i
can't have kinky hair i don't like the
color of my skin because i feel like
there's something wrong with me society
gave you that message your parents did
maybe a bully said something to you i
see somebody writing the way that i walk
i see somebody talking about the texture
of their hair i see somebody
saying i always felt like there was
something wrong with me well let me tell
you something everybody i never fit in
with any particular groups of friends
let me tell you something
every one of you is now going i remember
that feeling because i was the only
immigrant in my class i was uh the only
muslim in my class i didn't look like
the other people i didn't feel like the
other people my father was so critical
right
when you start to get this message from
society or other people or just this
perception that you have that
something's wrong with you this is where
your obsession with changing yourself to
fit in
begins this is where your obsession with
people pleasing this is where this sense
that you don't belong anywhere that you
go began
and it can become a habit and so we're
going to unpack this because what i want
you to understand is that you
literally
you literally came into this world
perfect whole and complete
you are wired to love yourself you're
wired for love that's why you miss it
you're wired for self-acceptance and the
world taught you
that there's something about you that
needs to be changed in order to be liked
or loved and it's simply not true
when you can come back home to yourself
and you can accept and love yourself
first exactly where you are exactly
where you're not
then you'll know the secret to going out
in the world and not feeling like you
never really belong anywhere or you
constantly need to tweak yourself or how
you show up in order
to be accepted by people when you accept
yourself as you are when you love
yourself as you are
other people liking or loving you is
just a bonus but it doesn't change how
you feel about yourself there will never
be another you
there never has been another you there
will never be another you that will ever
walk this earth
you are the one and only
which means you have something
extraordinarily unique to give to the
world
and feeling celebrated and feeling seen
and feeling heard
it is so tied into your existence
because of how unique you are that's why
you long
to be recognized as an individual that's
why you long to be celebrated as an
individual this need it's so important
and foundational to you and the fact
that your birth and existence is a
miracle
that it's as important to your
well-being to be seen and heard and
appreciated as food and water
the difference between a good day and a
bad day you know what it comes down to
typically is just being acknowledged by
somebody
and you know who's the best person to
acknowledge and validate you
you are
and that brings me back to that moment
every single morning when you come face
to face with yourself in the mirror
high-fiving yourself is so much more
than a physical act it's foundational
it's a transfer of energy it symbolizes
an alliance and a belief in yourself and
your ability
you aren't congratulating yourself
you're celebrating yourself as you are
and you just heard the math your
existence
is what makes you worthy of a high five
your presence your hopes your dreams
your capacity to love your ability to
heal to change to grow your heart your
soul
that's what makes you
worthy of being seen and heard
and appreciated
not once in a while
but every single day
that's what you deserve
that's what you need
and the miracle
of your existence is why you need it
see when you
are able
to see yourself
when you are able to celebrate yourself
when you are able to treat yourself in a
way that you have been wishing your
parents would have or wishing your
friends or your spouse or your boss
would
when you take control
this is what you communicate it's
incredible
you're basically when you're able to
hear yourself and see yourself and
support yourself and i believe that
simply adding a high five in the mirror
to yourself as part of your morning
routine
every single day you start the day by
fulfilling
those foundational needs that the
miracle of your birth demands of you
you're not celebrating the small wins
so as you make manifesting a skill as
you get consistent about it as you start
to be a student as you take inspired
action as you realize that you do feel
like this is going to happen you don't
even have a timeline on it because you
know it's going to happen
you're not as you're doing these things
recognizing all the small wins that you
have
every day
when you
manifest and then you take the action
that the manifesting has inspired that's
a win
when you see
doors opening up because you've been
moving toward what you want that's a win
when you randomly meet somebody that
introduces you to somebody that helps
you get one step closer that's a win
and you need to celebrate that stuff
these are signs these are not
coincidences
these are signs that you're on the right
path a lot of people believe in angel
signs you know like seeing the number 11
or 22 or the number nine or for me the
number five
angel signs are cool because for me
angel signs are a mile marker
that give you a clue that you're moving
in the right direction
your job is to
declare what you want
your job is to use manifesting to train
your mind body and spirit and remove the
obstacles that you would normally put in
place
your job is to take the actions that are
inspired by manifesting and start moving
toward what you want
you also though need to call out those
mile markers when you see it holy
i just got introduced to somebody in the
movie business and it's my dream and i'm
manifesting that i
have my script turned into a movie
this is a sign that i'm on the right
path and what you want to do is call
those things out not because the
universe or magic or this is somehow
just randomly happening
this is you being rewarded for
manifesting properly for believing in
yourself and for taking the inspired
action that is going to make your dreams
a reality and these little moments these
signs these small wins that are
happening every day as you make
manifesting a consistent skill that you
practice in the morning that you put to
use so that you are aligned with what
you want so that your mind body and
spirit is working with you instead of
against you when you start to also call
out the small winds there i am
manifesting there this thing happened
this is happening too there are my angel
numbers holy cow this just happened
you're now building momentum
you're now energetically rewarding your
body for aligning with what you want and
it just makes all of this that much
stronger it makes your belief stronger
it makes your courage bigger it makes
your confidence stronger that's how all
of this builds one on the other and if
you're not willing to call out the small
wins you're missing a huge amount of
mojo and rocket fuel and magic that you
can add into the mix because all of
these small wins are literally reasons
for you to be more confident reasons for
you to keep going reasons for you to
really know in your mind body and spirit
that yeah
this is gonna happen because you're
making it happen create habits of
empowering yourself because empowering
yourself
forgiving yourself supporting yourself
as you move forward and do the work to
change your life
that's how you break the habit of
victimizing yourself and that's how you
learn to do the opposite which is
supporting empowering cheering
celebrating yourself as you move forward
that's what's going to motivate you to
do the action and look if chris and i
can go from having liens on this house
six years ago
to literally building an extraordinary
business changing our marriage to the
point where we are
building our dream house a house that's
so nice i can't even believe we are
going to live in this house because of
the hard work that we've done but i'll
tell you the singular habit that helped
us do it
is we stopped victimizing ourselves we
stopped labeling ourselves we started
beating we stopped beating out of
ourselves
and we broke that habit we changed the
narrative
by learning how to empower ourselves be
yourself
be yourself let the world fit into who
you are
be yourself it's more important that you
be yourself and like yourself than
anything else everybody
and we've all bought into this whole
life because people taught you that this
is how the world works this is the
lesson i didn't mean to teach our son
that it's better to fit in than be
yourself
that uh i'll like you and love you if uh
the version of you is the one that i
like and love
ugh i hate that i did this and kids
if you're watching this i'm really sorry
and i'm sure your parents if you're not
my kids that are watching this
didn't mean to do it either
they didn't know any better this is how
their parents raised them i'm not saying
it's right i'm just saying this is what
so everybody
i hate that story but that's the heart
of what happened to you to me to
everybody you know you started
questioning what you look like and what
you do and ultimately who you are and
that's how your connection to your true
self gets blocked
that's why you stopped accepting
yourself it's why you started
criticizing yourself
it's why you stand in front of a mirror
and pick yourself apart because your mom
or dad used to do it to you
for our daughter or anyone who struggles
with their appearance you've got to
start to reverse this you got to learn
how to appreciate the parts of yourself
right now you got to stop trashing
yourself if you are pulling on a pair of
jeans and beating yourself up and
trashing yourself because they're tough
to pull on
uh
just dump the genes in the trash please
because when you criticize yourself and
you beat yourself up you're treating
yourself the way i treated our son
you are basically
treating yourself
the way i treated our son
you're saying your love for yourself is
transactional
until i approve of everything about your
life and the way you look i'm gonna
withhold the love and acceptance that
you need in life and it's a horrible way
to go
so you don't hate appreciate
you don't need to change anything to
deserve
the love and acceptance that you need
just like my son did not need to change
his blue hair
to be loved and accepted
to be loved and accepted for who you are
all i needed to do was love and accept
him exactly as he was
i made a huge mistake everybody
the next time you stand in front of a
mirror stop poking and prodding and
picking yourself apart for those of us
that put makeup on
let the makeup be a creative expression
something that's additive
and stop having the makeup be an act
where you cover yourself up because you
think you're ugly or you think that how
you look isn't okay if you're gonna wear
makeup do it as a creative expression do
it because it's fun don't do it because
you need to fix yourself because you
don't need to fix yourself just like my
son did not need to cut his hair
i needed to learn the lesson
that love is not transactional love is
unconditional
love is accepting somebody for exactly
who they are and where they are and how
they look and how they express
themselves that's what love is it's
accepting
someone
for everything that they are
and
everything that they're not
it's it's caring for somebody and
supporting and seeing somebody
for who they are right now where they
are right now
no matter what that may be
when you feel seen when you feel heard
and when you feel celebrated or accepted
for the contribution that you make as an
individual
unique individual
you feel safe
you feel like you belong
and at your core you feel
loved
when you don't feel seen
you feel invisible in life
when you don't feel heard you're going
to feel misunderstood
and when you don't feel like you are
accepted or validated
you feel completely rejected and
disconnected
you feel like you are unworthy or
unloved
and so again we're going to talk about
your need to be seen to be heard and to
be
accepted and celebrated you need this at
work you need this at home you need this
in your relationships your friendships
your romantic relationships your family
and you know if you just reflect in your
life where do you feel
seen
heard
and celebrated
where in your life do you feel that way
or is there a person in your life that
makes you feel that way
hopefully
you are saying that you make yourself
feel seen heard and celebrated
but
is there somebody else in your life that
makes you feel that way it could be a
caregiver it could be somebody that
you're in a romantic relationship with
it could be a mentor it could be a
friend it could be your pet right like i
mean
i think one of the reasons why we all
love our cats and our dogs so much is
because there's such unconditional love
you walk in the door they come running
right at you and so you feel seen and
you feel celebrated right and when
they're right there with you or you know
have you ever noticed how
when you get really upset
and you start crying what do your
animals do oh my god they hear you and
they come right on over
and i those responses that are so innate
when it comes to your pets everybody
they're
fulfilling your emotional needs that's
why you feel so safe and connected and
loved by your pets because you feel seen
by them you feel heard by them and you
feel
celebrated and loved by them and i do
see people saying i feel that way about
my daughter my mom a mentor of mine
these core values when they're missing
from your life
of being seen heard celebrated and
accepted
this is what leads you to feeling stuck
and disconnected and unfulfilled and the
good news is when you realize that these
core fundamental needs truly dictate
how you feel and experience your life
now you've got the access point to be
able to
change how you're experiencing your life
by focusing on
your core fundamental needs and making
sure that they are met
when's the last time
you felt excited
because you were up to something
that was either cool
or it was
new
or it was exciting
you know i think about times in my life
when i was up to something
it's like those moments of anticipation
i was applying to college or i was
applying to uh law school or i was
making a decision that i was going to
leave a job that i didn't like or even
after a breakup you know where you're
newly single and you feel like whoa
oh i love how many of you are saying
right now
right now i feel like i'm up to
something
right now
you know i feel like i could be a part
of something or maybe
for many of you who are saying ew i
don't feel that way mel i'm feeling like
my life is pretty stagnant it was a long
time ago i can't remember when
i wanna have you imagine something
imagine
how energizing and exciting it would be
to wake up every day and feel like
you're a part of something really cool
imagine
if you made a decision
that starting literally today
you were going to be up to something
you were going to push yourself you know
it makes me kind of sad everybody how
many of you are sitting there saying
um i can't even remember i've lost my
direction
and i want to tell you something
if you
feel lost if you feel stuck if you feel
like it has been
way too long since you've had something
that you've looked forward to
i um i want to tell you something
you deserve
you deserve to have that energy back in
your life you deserve to uh get the push
that you need because yet last night was
a reminder of something
you know it's so easy and i i know that
i can fall into this too it's so easy to
kind of get stuck in your rut especially
after working from home for two years
especially after coming through the
pandemic especially after being in this
routine of isolation and feeling like
nothing is ever going to change
last night for me being in new york city
and uh just coming down and being with
friends and seeing how energizing it is
to be around people that are up to
something it reminded me of this piece
of research that when you hear it it
sounds kind of stupid right but then
when you stop and think about it it's so
true
when researchers study happiness you
want to know something crazy about happy
people
happy people
are just prioritizing and making time to
do the little things that make them
happy
and what we also know and you know this
too
that when you look forward
and you see things in your calendar just
this weekend for example
just this weekend having something that
you've planned something that you're
going to be a part of that just having
something just out in the near future to
look forward to it gives you two bursts
of energy too
number one the planning of it makes you
think about it right and as you
anticipate it and you anticipate what
something is going to be like
you get this burst of energy and then
the doing of it
makes you feel energized and excited
again who can relate to this
you feel like you're not worthy of the
things that you're accomplishing or that
somehow this is luck or somebody's like
giving you a break but you didn't earn
it god every one of you that blows
really
so what you're dealing with
when you have impostor syndrome is
you're dealing with a lack of self-worth
you literally
kind of see all the things working out
but you've got this like annoying voice
in your head
that's saying you don't deserve this
this is luck how many of you have that
story this is locked this is going to
run out this isn't due to me
yeah we got to
literally destroy that voice
that is from your past
and part of the reason why you have that
that voice by the way is because of
racism
it's because of discrimination it's
because of childhood trauma it's because
of
uh various experiences that you've had
where either your
experience is growing up
or
society at large has made you feel
either overtly or in a really like gross
and sort of sly way like you don't
belong and so it is critical for you to
start to punch that voice literally out
of your head and i'm going to give you
some steps to do it okay
the second thing that's really important
is that in addition to stopping down
that voice because it's not your voice
that is somebody else's voice that your
brain listened to
and then started repeating
and the thing about your brain is that
your brain is this really cool computer
that learns patterns
and what i want you to understand
is that patterns
repeat
unless you break and replace them
and if you have a pattern of thinking
like what heidi has
that says you're not worthy
you don't deserve this
luck is going to run out at some point
the you know what's going to hit the fan
again
brace
don't count on anything like you didn't
earn this if you got that pattern
running in your head that is a broken
pattern
you're not broken
that pattern of thinking is broken
and so
the line in the sand that i want to draw
starting today
is you're not allowed to listen to that
garbage anymore
we are going to go on a mission together
to notice whenever it comes up oh
interesting there it is there's that
pattern it's spinning just like a load
of laundry right up there
and i'm going to teach you once you
recognize that pattern you're going to
use this thing that i created called the
5 second rule
you're going to count backwards 54321
because that shuts that down
and counting backwards let's all do it
together here we go five four three
two one now notice when you counted did
you feel a little pressure right here
yeah that was me hypnotizing you no i'm
just kidding um
what you are feeling
is by counting backwards it's a little
brain hack
that interrupts all the garbage that's
here in the interior part of your brain
this is where imposter syndrome lives
everybody this is where anxiety is this
is where self-doubt is this is where
self-criticism is this is where it's all
stored when you notice oh there's that
voice again and you count backwards five
four three two one you shut it down
and then you awaken this part of your
brain this is the part of the brain that
you used when you were taking the sats
this is the part of the brain that you
used when you applied for that job when
you speak up in that meeting when you
tell somebody no you cannot borrow my
dress tonight no
when you have boundaries right this is
the part of the brain that gives you
immediate control over what you think
and do next
and so
that's a really important thing number
one you're going to notice it one of the
things that will help you
to do the work to create the things that
you want in your life
is it will help you if you train your
mind
to start spotting
evidence
as you're doing the work as you're going
through your day it will help you
if you train your mind to start scanning
the world and spotting evidence
that yes indeed
the world is sending you positive
signals that things are going to work
out now why is it important to train
your mind to help you get what you want
well the reason why is because
if you get into a negative mindset if
you start thinking
this business is never going to work why
even bother i'm never gonna meet anybody
it's nothing but losers out there look
at all these idiots on hinge why the
hell should i keep doing this if you
allow your mind to start to rest in a
pessimistic
negative protective
scared and doubtful stance
your mind will continue to show you
reasons why there's nobody on hinge
worth talking to your mind will continue
to show you all the reasons why you will
never make it in business your mind will
continue to show you all the reasons why
you're never going to lose that weight
and be able to tuck in your shirt as my
friend corinne crabtree always talks
about that transformational moment and
when your mind goes negative your mind
starts to scan the world and will show
you more reasons to stop
and the power of training your mind to
spot positive signs is very simple
the power is that your mind will start
to show you reasons to keep going
your mind will help you take the step
your mind will encourage you to feel
optimistic to feel empowered just like
you woke up today on a tuesday
and it was february 22nd
2022 and those numbers are lining up and
that makes you in your heart and soul go
whoa
something cool could happen today like
that only happens like once in my
lifetime those numbers are gonna line up
like that today
is a really cool day let's go do
something with this
you could create that kind of attitude
every single freaking day of your life
you could
if you train your mind and if you start
taking action and training your mind is
the key piece that we're going to talk
about
so for those of you that have read the
high five habit one of the things that i
talk about a lot is every single day
find a naturally occurring heart-shaped
object in the world it could be a stone
it could be a leaf it could be a cloud
it could be a shape in your coffee hey
chris if we've got anything around here
that looks like a heart hand it to me
and the reason why i love telling you to
start playing a game with yourself where
you start your day going mind brain show
me some heart oh what is this come here
dog treat oh my god it's a dog treat
look at this guys
what shape is that
that right there is a heart there we go
check that out
if you say
brain
mind show me a heart today guess what's
going to happen that damn dog biscuit
it's going to show it's gonna you're
gonna be like there's a heart you're
gonna look out at the sky and you're
gonna see a heart shape oh right there
in the mountains there's a heart shape
in the mountains in southern vermont
you're gonna see it in the clouds what
you're doing when you tell your mind
what's important to you is you're
telling your mind and the filter in your
brain to change in real time and allow
into your consciousness
what's important to you and if you want
to see hearts by god those damn dog
treats are going to start looking like
hearts everybody that's how you train
your mind it's freaking incredible and
if you want to see evidence of this
follow me on social media if you follow
me mel robbins on social media you will
see every day i am re-posting your
stories of finding heart shapes around
the world now why is this important well
it's important because it's a simple way
to prove to you that your mind changes
in real time that if you get serious
about becoming more positive and
optimistic and encouraging of yourself
if you get serious about saying this i
don't wanna see all the reasons why i'm
unhappy i don't wanna see
uh everybody else in the world that's
launched a business or that's lost
weight and is healthy or that has a
really good uh marriage or relationship
and i don't want to see that and and and
have my mind process it as evidence that
it's never going to happen for me
i want my mind to reprogram itself and
see other people's businesses and see
other people getting healthy and see
other people in relationships and i want
my mind to say
yeah if they can do it i can do it
that's evidence if that person can get
healthy so can i if that person can find
somebody on hinge so can i if that
person can reconcile with their child so
can i
other people can become evidence that
you can have it too right now your mind
is so
from your past that when you see what
other people have and you don't have it
you can't actually translate it through
a negative mind and and see that that's
evidence that you're going to win you
see it like oh somebody already stole
what i wanted that sucks and so what i
want to start to open your mind to is
that you have the power to train your
mind
to filter the world differently just
like you woke up and you saw the date
today 2 22 22 and your brain saw that
was like whoa
this is a once in a lifetime day
everybody
you are never going to have another day
that lines up like this ever
what are you going to do with this day
your mind already interpreted this as
wow
something cool could happen
and if you tell yourself something
amazing is going to happen today
something will because you're going to
be looking for it i swear to god
something will
something will if you want to see the
good all around you you got to tell your
mind you want to see the good and this
just isn't a bunch of everybody this
isn't toxic positivity there is a filter
in your brain called the reticular
activating system
the reticular activating system i call
it the ras i like to think about it like
a giant hair net on your head and this
ras sits over your brain i'm probably
getting this wrong i'm not a
neuroscientist i could give about
getting it right i just need you to know
the basics here so that you can apply it
to your life okay you don't need a phd
to use the science that super smart
people have been working really hard on
in order to apply it to your life
that's what i'm here for in your life
i'm here to translate this stuff into
simple believable and actionable things
that you can do to take all this super
cool stuff that people are researching
and apply it to your normal person's
everyday life to
help you
change from the inside out and one of
the coolest things that you have at your
disposal is you have
a whole system in your body that you can
train and change
and one of those things that you can
train and change
that is impacted by that real that word
you're hearing a lot of neuroplasticity
that just means that things are able to
twist and bend and change and you're
able to learn new things for as long as
you're alive
as long as you're breathing everybody
you got a chance to change the way that
you think as long as you are breathing
you got a chance to change from the
inside out how you experience your life
as long as you are still here watching
me people you got a chance to create a
new experience in your life and one of
the things that helps a lot is
understanding that right now
all of the
from your past has jammed the filter in
your mind body and spirit the reticular
activating system and it is clouding
your ability to look at the world around
you and see
hearts remember this dog treat hearts
look at that there's a heart right there
do
tiny things every day that boost your
mood okay
so we're gonna build your mood muscle
if you can
move your body
because negativity gets stored here and
moving your body we know based on the
research simply moving your body for 10
or 20 minutes a day will release
chemicals in your mind
that help you boost your mood
the second thing that will boost your
mood is i want you to make a tiny
promise to yourself every day just one
thing that makes you feel more positive
is it getting up on time
is it eating something healthy
is it only having one glass of wine or
reaching for a mocktail i want you to
put one tiny promise into place put it
into the um comments right now what's
one tiny promise that you can make to
yourself that you're going to do every
day it might just be that you're going
to wake up every day take a deep breath
remind yourself that you're healthy and
that's going to be the tiny promise i
want you to do one tiny promise every
day because keeping a promise
to yourself will boost your mood and
make you feel more in control another
way to build your mood muscle is
have a zero tolerance policy for your
own negative thoughts
right now as you edit social media and
edit your news take and edit your
negativity coming in from the outside
world
do not tolerate negativity from the
inside world i woke up this morning i
looked in the mirror
i looked at the gray hairs that are
coming in particularly like right up
here
and i started to go negative
i started to feel dreary and i went mel
cut this out you gotta fight to stay
positive gal because we are in this for
another couple months and do not succumb
to despair do not start thinking
negative stuff when you have negativity
internally you gotta have a zero
tolerance policy for that it's one thing
to feel what you need to feel
so that you can move through it it's
another thing to let negativity dwell up
here and start ruminating fi the five
second rule is genius for this count
backwards the second that negative five
54321
not listening to it no i am redirecting
my thoughts that's right i am looking
for the things i can control i am
keeping a positive attitude by focusing
on things that i can control right now
today
got it good so the other stuff that's
super cool about this is that you know
we've all bought into this lie that
somehow beating yourself up and tough
love and being hard on yourself is
motivating
wrong
all the research shows that it is
demotivating if you're somebody that's
stuck if you're somebody that has
regrets if you're somebody that is tired
of where you are if you feel like you
know you just why can't i change
beating yourself up is making it worse
you have to learn
how to cheer for yourself
where you are
because if you're not you will never
find the motivation to change so they
did this study with kids where they
broke kids into three different groups
okay
and they gave the kids very challenging
problems and they wanted to know what
was going to be
the thing that researchers could do to
motivate and inspire kids to work
through a challenging problem and
what is going to be the most effective
thing that we could do to give somebody
that boost that you need to really face
something that's hard so group number
one got the old fixed mindset praise
where it's like hey you're super smart
rich hey rich you're really good looking
in those glasses and i bet they help you
make you focus on this problem keep
going buddy
the second group got the fixed mindset
praise which is hey rich you're really
really working hard rich that
perseverance is amazing keep going the
third group
they got a simple high five
no words
just a high five
the group with the simple high five
outperformed the other two group and
then some that's why
why i'll tell you why a high five is
fulfilling
your fundamental emotional needs it's
not about the problem when you high-five
somebody including yourself you are
affirming that somebody exists
you are saying i see you
and you're celebrating with them you
know how those things go viral uh all
year long of of uh teachers standing
outside their classroom doing individual
handshakes with kids it's the same thing
every one of those kids is being seen as
an individual and celebrated
your past has completely
the reticular activity system
the reason why you doubt yourself the
reason why you think nothing works out
for you the reason why you're seeking
validation from everybody else is
because your life trained you to do that
and i'm here to tell you you can wake
the hell up
and you can realize
that from this moment forward you
have the ability using simple and
believable tools
to reclaim
your mind body and spirit to retrain it
and to use it to help you
feel the way that you want to feel to
experience life the way that you want to
experience life and to build a sense of
momentum
as you go through your day and you start
to see
all kinds of stuff around you as
evidence that you can have it too i'll
give you a simple example so as many of
you know for a very long time i've
always wanted to launch a podcast i got
my start in the media business back in
2007
by having a local radio show in boston
massachusetts on a talk radio station on
saturday mornings that's what i did i
made 25 an hour i hosted a show for two
hours a live call-in show where we
talked about what was going on in the
world it was an advice show i absolutely
loved it and from there uh that show
grew it then uh became a sunday night
show in atlanta and then i got a five
day a week show in orlando so you're
looking at a woman who got her start in
the media business doing local radio i
paid for our kids braces by reading
invisalign ads for the local dentist so
i have been in sort of the radio or
podcast business
since 2007 since before podcasts and
then my life took detours like it did i
have not been in radio since god 2011
maybe so long time 10 years and i've
been thinking about launching a podcast
for five years everybody five years
and every time i would think about it
my mind would look around and
my mind my reticular activity system the
filter in my brain was clogged with all
kinds of crap
and when i looked around and i saw all
these people launching podcasts
that
fact of seeing it would filter through
my mind and my mind would say
there's no room for you you're too late
you're not going to be as good as those
other people
so my
mind was looking
at the outside world
and the fact that everybody and their
mother was launching a podcast five
years ago and they still are today
and it would pass through the filter in
my brain
and my brain would say to me mel you're
you might as well just stop thinking
about it because you're too late woman
how many of you do that to yourself that
you see other people having what you
want and the way that that
fact that somebody else has gotten
healthier somebody else has made a
million dollars or somebody else has
launched a business online or somebody
else has
found somebody after divorce and is
happier than ever and you see that and
you immediately assume it's never going
to happen for me instead of having your
brain go
whoa
look at that
look all these people out there doing
this if they can do it you can do it too
mel look at that you got all these
people that can give you advice you got
all these people that are lights on the
path that you want to walk down how cool
is that you got all kinds of information
all kinds of help all kinds of evidence
that's positive
well the reason why my mind didn't see
it as positive is the same reason why
your mind does not see everybody else's
business and everybody else's health
journey and everybody else's bank
account and everybody else's fancy
vacations or when you walk into a bar
and all your girlfriends get hit on
instead of you
your mind
does not see all of that as evidence
that it's going to eventually work out
for you because your mind is clogged
with all kinds of crap from your past
and i'm here to tell you
when you wake up and realize
that you could train your brain to wake
up every day and go holy today's going
to be a magical day today is going to be
that 2 22 22 day where you immediately
see this you know this is the one day of
your life where this is going to be the
day come on in jesse
jesse's here
hey yolo
yolo come on in you could you could
literally train your mind
to wake up every day and go damn it i'm
gonna see a heart today and i'm gonna
see evidence today that it's working out
for me and when my mind starts to see
that this is going to work out for me
i'm going to feel more empowered i'm
going to feel more inspired and i'm
going to keep going because the bottom
line is everybody your positive mindset
helps you with momentum repetition and
discipline your
positive mindset helps you
by encouraging you to take the action
because as you know
because you hang out with me mel robbins
thinking about changing your life is not
gonna change your life
the only thing that changes your life is
action
you want something different you gotta
do something different
but a
filter in your brain that filters the
world in a positive way in an
encouraging way a filter in your brain
that acts more like that annoying friend
you know that annoying friend who's
always trying to to build you up and i
say annoying because when you're
committed to being like it's never
working out for me i'm never going to
meet anybody i'm never going to lose the
weight and your friend's like oh
are you kidding you know how amazing you
are you're like
don't tell me i'm amazing i want to feel
terrible
so when you start to change your brain
when you start to really go to work on
this filter
you're going to turn your own mind from
a critic
and somebody who's nasty
into that friend that's really cheering
you on see see this is going to work out
for you see you should keep going see
this is really good for you to do and
that's why it's important
it's really hard to take action
when you have a mindset
it's really hard
to find what's called the activation
energy the force to push yourself
through the resistance and the fear
if you are committed to believing
that it's not
worth doing anyway
and so
action is critical
action is where the five second rule
comes in
but if you want to supersize this and
step on the accelerator you must start
to train your mind
and one way you can start to do this is
to look for hearts every day that's one
chapter in the book we haven't read yet
see this is a dog treat that was shaped
like a heart i asked chris he scanned
the room boom that's how this works the
other way
that you can start to train your mind is
to learn about the filter in your brain
to learn about the fact that this filter
in your mind
has the ability to change in real time
what you see
if you
are afraid of disappointing people
if you're afraid that you're not good
enough
you may catch that in one area of your
life but as your life gets bigger and as
you change it'll creep in in other areas
and one way that those patterns where
you don't think you deserve it or you
don't think you're good enough or you're
terrified of disappointing people
comes into play is when you start to
expect the worst
and so
catch it that's the first step you can't
break your pattern unless you see it
and then you're gonna replace it and
what i'm gonna start doing is i've got
this little app on my watch you can set
it on your phone where
every like three hours it reminds me to
breathe and i notice the second that the
alarm goes off i've been holding my
breath
and so you can set a little alarm in
your phone megan's laughing you can set
a little alarm in your phone that just
says savor it's a reminder to take a
minute you can make it say take a minute
take a minute look around comp your
compliment yourself on what's going
right because
expecting the worst is something you
taught yourself to do guess what you can
teach yourself to take a minute
and to savor what's going right and the
more you force yourself to do it the
more it'll become a habit no matter
what's happening around or to you you
hold the power
because you always have the power to
have an honest conversation you always
have the power to discuss how things are
impacting you you always have the power
to make requests and you certainly have
the power to draw boundaries and you
also have the power by the way if the
culture gets worse and worse or you just
are tired of it because it's not
changing to go find a different job
the power is always in you and i think
that's something that's so important to
constantly remind yourself i get that i
don't like where i am but what could i
do to change it
how can i change how i think about this
and i'm telling you right now you know
this the second you start changing how
you think about a situation the
situation changes the second you start
changing how you think about what your
options are you start to see them the
second you stop thinking that you're
stuck or that you're a victim and you
start thinking about how you solve
something you start to see solutions and
so the answer is always in you if you
look at
human development we're the only species
that literally can't survive without
another human being taking care of you
and so we are biologically
hard-wired to bond with other people and
that is the ver from the very beginning
of when you come out
bonding with somebody else and making
sure they pay attention to you is your
survival imperative so you are born
needing somebody else and i think what
ends up happening is there's never that
kind of clean
break or pass off between
needing your parents to take care of you
needing your friends approval to fit in
to truly having ownership over giving
yourself what you didn't get giving
yourself what you needed and that's the
piece that i've been doing a lot of
during the the great pause is slowing
down because so much of my busyness
was fueled by uh you know praise me love
me am i doing enough you know please
tell me i'm doing okay okay i can
breathe now i'm okay now
and when i slow down and maybe it's a
function of the anxiety that's when
things get scary because that's when
you've really got to be with yourself
one of the things that i have to do is i
have to
stop holding on to misery i've got to
stop holding on to
my own habit of hesitating and
overthinking and feeling scared and
gripping
and i'm working on it um
so i want to know what are you getting
out of this
and i see oh i love this i see so many
of you going oh my god happiness is so
unfamiliar happiness is so unfamiliar
trauma that you haven't released i
relate to this holy cow i'm so glad that
you do
i remember um a couple months ago i was
doing a bunch of research for um a
project that we're doing for audible
about
happiness was one of the episodes that
we were working on
and it was kind of striking to me
that
the research around happiness
shows that folks that feel happier and
are present to more joy in their life
have a habit that
those of us that sort of grip tightly
and feel a little wound up and stressed
and have a hard time relaxing don't have
and that habit that happy people have
is that they
make time to do things
that make them feel happy
and when i started digging into that
research it was a little confronting
because i thought
i don't even allow myself i'm so gripped
to feeling stressed out and intense and
bracing for what's next that i haven't
even made it a priority to allow myself
and so becoming a happier person again
i'm going to go back to what i said
earlier in this broadcast
the first step is
literally letting go stop gripping
let go of what's no longer serving you
because holding on to it hurts a hell of
a lot more than letting go of it
and so wherever in your life you are not
happy or you are
just bracing or stressed or stuff isn't
working i guarantee you you're gripping
onto something a relationship a job a
habit a routine a place that you live a
mindset you're gripping on to something
that no longer serves you
and gripping to it is going to cause you
so much more pain and misery
than letting go
it's really that simple
every single ending in your life has a
brand new beginning contained into it
that's it every single ending that you
are
avoiding
in your life
inside that ending there is a new
beginning i am right in the thick of
this which is why i'm talking about it
for years
hesitation
kept me trapped in my head
hesitation
made me doubt myself
hesitation kept me from
taking the actions and
taking the small risks
that change your life
and you
have a habit of hesitating
hesitating is this little habit that we
all have and you know i obviously
invented the five second rule which is a
tool that you can use
to push through
the hesitation that holds you back
and to break that habit of hesitating
and to replace it with an action
of moving forward
but there's an area in your life where
you are hesitating
you know what you want or you at least
know you don't want what you currently
have
and you think a lot about what you need
to do or what you could do or what you
wish would happen
and all that thinking that you're doing
that is
the problem
you're not going to change your life
you're not going to get what you want
if all you do is think about it
and
i want to challenge you
i think that there is some change you
want to make something that you want to
do and you're sitting there questioning
it whether it's
going back to school or launching that
business or moving to a different place
or breaking up with somebody or
changing up your exercise program
there's something that you want to do
and i want you to put in the comments
what's that thing that you really want
to have a breakthrough in or you want to
change but all you do is think about it
and think about it and think about it
maybe it's your job maybe it's your
health maybe it's your relationship the
habit of hesitating of questioning
i think it kills more happiness more
possibility more dreams than fear
failure and every excuse that you have
because it's so subtle
you see what happens to you
is that throughout your day you are
going through your day and as you bump
into people or you have experiences or
you see things on social media or you're
reading a book you have this
impulse or this inspiration this moment
where you're like oh gosh i'd really i'd
love to launch a business like that or
oh i'd love to launch a podcast or maybe
i should write a book someday or you
know whoa uh i should really get serious
about that thing that i want to do
and then
instead of taking a step forward
you stop and think about it
so i see stephen wants to stop smoking i
see that um
you know a lot of you want to launch a
business or change your job learn how to
invest in real estate full time that
there's a lot that you're thinking about
but this moment of hesitation
what happens when you stop and think is
you literally get trapped in your head
and the more that you think about this
thing whether it's real estate investing
or launching a business or changing your
health or quitting smoking or
uh
whatever it may be
maybe it's just mindset maybe you just
wish you weren't so negative all the
time maybe you wish you could be happier
that's something i'm working on in this
chapter of my life
learning how to allow myself
to be happier
learning how to be okay with everything
that's happening and everything that's
not i mean that would be a huge change
for somebody like me who is so type a
and so hard charging
and so driven to learn how to just be
happy and okay no matter what's
happening
that that would be enough
that's something i'm working on but
thinking about it that's not gonna help
so as you write down
an area of your life where you're
hesitating i wanna tell you the simple
truth
the only thing that is going to change
that relationship that job your
financial situation your attitude your
mental health your friendships your
relationship with your family the only
thing that's going to change that is
action
you gotta learn how to launch through
the excuses the fear all of that crap
that's holding you back
do you feel overwhelmed right now
yes oh okay i'm not the only one that
feels overwhelmed okay good um
i find it very comforting
when i know that i'm not the only person
who feels a certain way
and whether you are overwhelmed right
now
because of your job or because of your
health or because of what you're seeing
unfold in the news or the world around
you or whether you're overwhelmed
because you just have so much on your
plate you feel like you are standing
underneath an avalanche
i hate that i see so many hearts going
because that's a terrible place to be
i want to share
a surprisingly
simple
thing that you can do
in order to deal
with
overwhelm
and the reason why i say that this is
surprising
is because whenever you feel overwhelmed
isn't it true that the last thing that
you want to do is take on anything else
you're sort of like i can't do one more
thing
i barely have time to go the bathroom
i'm so overwhelmed
and
that's why what i'm about to recommend
is incredibly surprising
because this is going to seem like it's
super counter-intuitive
as a solution based on research and
based on for sure my personal experience
as a solution to moments in time where
you feel overwhelmed by life or by the
world or by what you're facing
now what is that surprisingly simple
solution as a way to deal with overwhelm
well
the surprisingly simple solution
is to
take on
a simple
little challenge that you're going to
take on every day you're going to
take on something
that uh
aligns with growth and change
it pushes you
forward and
it gives you something to look forward
to every day because part of the reason
why
overwhelm is so debilitating is because
when you're overwhelmed
your focus is scattered across
absolutely everything
and you're thinking about your family
and your health and the news and the
this and that and the presentation and
the emails you didn't do
and at the end of the day
each and every one of those things
is not really that important
there's probably can we agree one two or
three things a day that really matter
that really need your attention
and the reason why we get so freaking
overwhelmed
with life as we allow our attention to
get scattered and to get pulled in a
bazillion different directions
and the solution
to feeling more in control and to
literally dealing with overwhelm which
is just an overwhelming amount of things
that really most of which are not that
all important to you but they're just
distracting you which then pulls your
attention away from what really matters
you see i'd rather have you do two or
three things a day that really matter to
you and let the rest just kind of fall
where they fall right
and so the surprisingly simple
way
to deal with overwhelm is to pick one
thing that you're going to focus on
every day for you like no matter what
you're going to do this thing you're
going to add a little structure you're
going to add something that you're
committing to as a way to laser your
focus on something that's in your
control
it's absolutely awesome how this works
visualize the steps that lead you
to the thing that you want
not the end goal
this is a major mistake that people make
they manifest
improperly because all they do is focus
on the end goal
if you've ever made a vision board
think about what you put on the vision
board you put up just the beach house or
the million dollars in the bank are you
crossing the finish line are you
launching that business or you having
the body that you want are you a driving
the maserati whatever it is the end goal
is what you put up on a vision board
that is not what you're going to do when
you manifest if you start focusing on
crossing the finish line of the marathon
that is a one-way ticket to being
unmotivated and completely discouraged
in fact research shows that if all you
do is focus on the thing that you want
and you just focus on that vision of you
and your bikini body or you with the
love of your life on your arms or you at
the
oscars winning that award or the grammys
what happens is because you've only
focused on the end goal
you start to feel really unmotivated and
discouraged because you're nowhere near
it
that's where manifesting comes in
because we're not going to focus on the
end goal
you got to pick something that you want
in order to get started but manifesting
isn't about the end
it's about the bridge
it's about going from where you are here
to where you want to go
imagine that there is a bridge
that connects where you are right here
with what you dream about doing
now that dream could be to be a grammy
award-winning
singer-songwriter that dream might be to
have a family of your own that dream
might be to have a beach house or a ski
house or to take a trip to fiji that
dream can be whatever the hell you want
it to be
but when it comes to manifesting
once you've given yourself permission to
dream with the lid off and really want
what you want to feel the pull of that
thing now we got to talk about the path
that connects where you are with where
you want to go
and this is all about visualizing the
little steps there's a lot of research
that proves why visualizing the steps
is
the most important thing that you could
do
there was a study done at ucla for
example
where they were researching
manifestation and the power of
visualization and they broke students
into two groups and they had group a
we're going to call these the vision
board group they had group a
close their eyes visualize in their mind
and feel in their body
themselves taking the test
and then walking up
to a board where the tests
scores were posted
and finding their name and seeing an
a-plus
that's what group a the vision board
group were told to do
to visualize themselves achieving what
they wanted
group b
we're going to call these the hard
workers these students were coached in
this research project to close their
eyes and to visualize going back to
their dorm room
sitting down at the desk
and studying
and staying up late and putting in the
work studying and preparing for the
tests
now let me ask you a question
which group do you think did better on
the actual test
was it group a the vision board group
who were taught to visualize and picture
themselves walking up to a board and
seeing the a plus
or was it group b
the hard work group
the group that was taught to close their
eyes and visualize and seeing themselves
doing the work to study for the test
well if you answered group a you're
wrong
if you answered group b
you got the correct answer the reason
why group b
the students who visualize studying for
the test got better test scores is
because when you visualize yourself
doing the work visualizing it leads you
to doing the work
and it's only through actions that you
will get the result that you want
preparing your mind and visualizing
yourself doing it
lowers your resistance and leads to you
taking the action that's why manifesting
works you know the same is true in
sports there's all kinds of research in
sports psychology in fact our olympic
athletes for the u.s olympic team
they hire sports psychologists to train
our top olympic athletes particularly
after they've been injured
in
visualizing themselves competing
when you coach an athlete to mentally
rehearse every single detail about going
through the competition you are training
the mind body and spirit to show up and
dominate this is particularly true for
athletes after they've been injured and
they're stepping back into competition
if you've been injured in competition
you're naturally going to feel anxious
you're naturally going to be nervous
your brain and nervous system circuitry
is now programmed with the intensity
from that injury the memory from the
injury so of course it's natural to
bring that in to your
pre-competition feelings about it right
so manifestation properly remember what
it is manifesting is preparing your mind
body and spirit to do the work it's
aligning your mind body and spirit with
what you want it removes the obstacles
that would normally stop you which then
prepares and motivates you to take the
actions to succeed so in the case of
athletes who visualize themselves and
see themselves doing all the steps over
and over they're removing the nerves
they're removing all the programming
related to the injury they are preparing
their mind body and spirit to go in and
frickin dominate and so are you i think
that the work that we all have to do
every single one of us whether you
bulldoze
whether you people please
whether you avoid conflict
whether you're impulsive
whether you uh yo-yo your decisions
uh
whatever it is that is your pattern
you know you the the constant trashing
yourself
i think the the the journey of your
whole life
is figuring out how to truly
like
and love yourself the reason why it's so
important to start with a friend cleanse
and i'm sure a lot of you how many of
you heard that and you thought oh my god
getting rid of people oh boy oh boy i'm
going to cleanse these friends
yes and no
a friend cleanse is critical because the
single most influential thing around you
are the people that you hang out with
and if you have relationships
that are toxic if you have relationships
that cause guilt if you have
relationships that are creating drama in
your life if you have relationships that
are not equitable guess what
that's creating the overwhelm that's
creating unhappiness that's
keeping you doubting yourself if you
have friends that um have bad habits
guess what that's making it really
really hard for you to change your
habits for the good i know
that in this next chapter that i
consciously create i want to have more
fun
i want to i really want to love the
process yeah i don't want to make it so
hard on myself and be gripping
everything so tight and it's really easy
for me to see it in other people because
i know what it feels like in here
i'm working hard to break the patterns
that still hold me back and the big one
that holds me back is um bulldozing it's
literally when i start to feel
any level of tension this is
particularly true in my marriage um i'm
married to a saint thank god chris
robbins meditates every morning it's the
only reason why we've lasted 26 years
um it's how he puts up with me when i
feel
my like whatever emotion rise i
immediately raise my voice
it's how i assert power in the
relationship
and i am so committed louis
to
breaking that pattern wow and being a
more fun person to be around and a
kinder person to be around
first of all stop talking about passion
stop talking about launching a business
okay
when you think about it too big
it will paralyze you
if you're lucky and you're in a position
where
your bills are getting paid
and you have the luxury of being able to
try to think about what you want to do
in this next chapter
here's where i want you to start
i want you to start with what energizes
you now how ironic is that given that
i'm speaking at the energetic women's
conference here in indianapolis today
why am i saying energizes you and what
do i talk what am i talking about when i
say energize
when i say energizes you
i'm asking you what is it that you're
curious about
what is it that you feel so
expanded you feel energized you feel
kind of excited whenever you're doing it
you're in a phase when you're just
trying to figure out what's your next
move
of just paying attention to your
curiosity paying attention to the things
that interest you truth is
passion is just energy
if you're passionate about something it
means you're energized when you do it so
let's reverse engineer this and let's
just
ask yourself a simple question
what are you curious about what
energizes you and if you allow yourself
to explore things that energize you
you my friend will start to
find the clues about what it is that you
should and could be doing because all
the research says that if you're doing
something that you like
if you're doing something that you're
curious about you're not only going to
enjoy it you're going to be really good
at it because if you like doing it
you'll spend more time doing it which
means you're going to get better at it
you know sometimes when the dream is so
big the fact that it's so big becomes
paralyzing
because you think about where you are
right now and you think holy cow that
thing that i really want
i don't even like how do you even start
when the dream is so big
so here's what we're going to do today
we're going to shrink it down because
you know me i am all about simplicity
i'm all about making sure that the
advice works for you because if it
doesn't work for you you're not going to
do it and i'm all about switching how
you think about things making this
smaller
and making it something that i'm
learning about rather than doing and
launching and
that somehow thinking about it
differently frees up the ability to get
started if i get you to start doing that
and you do this every day for 10 or 15
minutes which you absolutely can guess
what's going to happen
you're going to feel momentum you're
going to feel like you're working on it
you're going to meet people that are
interested in it you're going to learn
things that are going to lead to the
next thing that you need to learn and
you will have mastered the art of
getting started and by doing something a
little bit every day you're also going
to master the art of continuing to keep
going and from there it'll snowball i
promise you i promise you you're only
ever running against yourself there's
room for all of us there's room for you
to do the same thing there's room for
you to write that book there's room for
you to do those makeup tutorials there's
room for you to launch that restaurant
there's room for you to start your
singing lessons there's room for you to
write that song it is normal and it is
going to happen to you all the time that
you're going to see people that seem to
block out the sun whenever they make an
announcement because they're that big
and that amazing i don't want you to
allow yourself to shrink when somebody
else is doing something that is
similar to what you want to do also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video i've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the lessons learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
i love myself because i feel comfortable
in my own skin
i love myself everybody because i don't
label myself as a bad or selfish or
broken or whatever person
i just
encourage myself i give myself
compassion and i work hard every
day
to maintain that kind of relationship
with myself
i have truly stopped victimizing myself
and i have empowered myself by
encouraging and being compassionate with
myself
and you're meant to feel this way about
yourself too
this is how you're meant to feel you're
you're meant to feel comfortable in your
own skin you're meant to feel proud of
yourself you're meant to feel celebrated
and encouraged by yourself and look
i still don't live on the right street i
still don't belong to that country club
i can't go back and redo my college and
my law school years
but
here's what i can tell you
you can break the habit of beating
yourself up over the past
you can break the habit of constantly
victimizing and bashing yourself you can
break the habit of labeling yourself
with these horrible labels and indicting
yourself
by
saying you are this way
no the behavior that you engaged in may
have sucked back then but you don't suck
you're just a human being and you're
figuring things out and now that you
know
what you need to do better you can do
better
you have this behavior pattern where you
snap you have this behavior pattern
where you yell and you get upset and you
make people wrong and you don't mean to
if you
are somebody who's ever said to yourself
i wish i could stop yelling or i wish i
i i i could just snap i could stop
snapping
this video
is absolutely unbelievable
okay and the reason why is i explained
this research that was so
mind-blowing for me
it's called ghosts in the nursery a lot
of the patterns that you have
that you don't have control over
are patterns from your childhood
and they
are there because when you were a kid
you experienced people in your life that
were tense
did you ever have a parent that was a
yeller
did you ever have a teacher that was a
yeller or a coach that was a yeller and
secretly in your little kid body
whenever your mom or dad would yell or
your coach would yell or your teacher
would yell or your grandmother or
grandfather would yell you would feel
tense right
you would feel nervous you would feel on
edge of course that's how we all feel
right well here's the reason why
you might have an issue like i used to
have an issue where i would yell at my
kids and then i'd feel terrible about it
i'd snap at my husband and then i'd feel
terrible about it psychologists and then
i would say to myself i'm not doing that
again i'm not doing that again but i
wouldn't have the ability to end it
psychologists call this ghost in the
nursery
it means that any situation where you
start to feel
tense or you start to feel stressed out
guess what happens your body remembers
what it was like when you were little to
feel tense and stressed out and what
were the adults doing around you when
you felt that way
they were snapping
they were yelling and now here you are
repeating the pattern and you don't know
why
and you feel guilty
and i'm explaining this to you because
it wasn't until i thought holy cow like
i know i don't want to snap at my
husband i know i don't want to take my
anger from work out on my family why
can't i stop this
that's the reason why it's because it's
a pattern that you remember from being a
kid that the adults around you were
snapping or yelling or being mean
any time and when they were you felt
tense and stressed out so now that
you're an adult when you're tense and
stressed out you repeat the behavior
that you witnessed crazy right so how do
you stop it well the first step to
stopping anything is to actually
understand what you're dealing with
now that you know you're dealing with a
pattern now all you need to do is
basically say okay i'm going to put a
practice in place that's going to
interrupt this pattern what's the
practice well a really good one is um
before you walk in the house at the end
of the day if you're stressed out take
five
take five deep breaths
like reset your mood reset your energy
before you walk in the house and you'll
be surprised by how much nicer you are
to the people around you
another thing that um that uh
you can do and this one's not so fun
is you can train your
partner your kids your roommates your
family that if you're trying to get a
hold of how you bring stress home you
can train them to say to you hey
don't take your work stress out on me
when somebody that you care about says
that to you it's a humbling experience
and the person that says it the most in
my life is my son oakley your uh the
youngsters seem to love to cross-check
the adults so be careful with taking
that advice because you made it this far
in a video i want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe nation you made it here
all the way to the end and i love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
below on this video i will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome to see my recent one-on-one with
mel robbins check the interview right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there i hope your business goes bankrupt
evan evan you're a terrible person i
spent the first 40-some years of my life
trying to be somebody else i'll give you
guys a secret way